jouer voici joey starr
et
non franchement à la loire vous
connaissez tous le monde jouait ici on
est plus ou moins alors on va écouter
votre single inquiète toujours
non c'est pas de single en ce moment ça
je resterai gazelles qui figure sur la
bande son du film astérix et obélix
mission cléopâtre d'alain chabat
alors comment ça se passe à la radio la
à la radio très skyrock
voilà sûrement sky bosse on est premiers
nationale au samedi donc heureusement
que ça se termine à 22 heures ça nous en
ait pas trop de clients
samedi mais je dis ça commence à minuit
donc vous n'êtes pas là je mena c'est
une chance pour nous peut-être un et à
partir du 4 janvier joey starr à 20h du
lundi au vendredi à 20h50 le samedi vous
êtes sur canal+ pour une émission qui
s'appelle 60 jours et 60 nuits vous
allez être suivie nuitées jours par une
caméra comme ozzy osbourne l'a été sur
mtv aux états unis vous avez accepté
volontiers de faire sa voix j'ai mal au
début mais ouais puis c'est pas comme
ozzy osbourne vu que c'est pas
scénarisée
j'ai pas donné rouge vin quotidien là
c'est mon quotidien car ajoute pas ce à
quoi comme il se doit et rien inventé
pas mal hein inventé avec vous et la
caméra vous suivent nuitées jours ouais
ouais casse les couilles comme ça ils
sont là ah oui prennent l'habitude et
j'aurais même devenus des petits ont
déjà ça se passe pas par dans catherine
quel petit nom vous leur avez donné
devant de catherine barma qui vous adore
chouchou et connard tu joues econav à la
quatrième je suis servi c'est que c'est
ce qui donne de catherine barma joey
starr ce qui c'est la coproductrice de
l'émission
ok elle vous adore si vous pouvez lui
faire une photographe avant de partir
parce que est très très fan de vous
alors l'émission ça me gêne pas que
cette émission soit produite par endemol
qui produit loft story star academy
on ne peut pas plaire à tout le monde
non personnellement moi ça me dérange
pas après tout ça c'est de la musique ça
se passe avec mon manager je n'ai pas
fair a eu directement donc lanvin après
j'ai un droit de regard que je pense que
à partir de là c'est vous qui avez ouais
c'est vous qui avez comme on dit le
final cut quoi ouais c'est bon alors moi
personne au départ je n'étais pas super
chaud et puis finalement ça se passe
bien voir là le bordel chez moi un truc
de dingue
ils essaient des bonus à doha c'est
peut-être vous qu elle est sauvée canal
joey starr ouais non c'est la merde hein
en fait les cas on a hâte de voir
ouais merci